over the course of six weeks in summer
of 2014
Market Basket employees joined by their
customers protested against the firing
of their beloved CEO they risk their
jobs their livelihoods and they brought
the business to a halt at a time when we
see so much division between the CEOs
who represent the top 1% and the workers
who represent the bottom 99% this level
of support for a CEO got the attention
of the entire country Arthur demoulas he
stands for valuing people
he always says we are in the people
business first grocery business second
and when the ownership change you start
asking questions what's gonna happen
with our benefits what's gonna happen
with our pay and when you start taking
away that factor of focusing on people
the entire business model starts to fall
apart
the workers were fighting for a business
model that works for everyone
for them for their customers and for
their shareholders we saw a number of
critical business lessons that emerge
from Market Basket let me share with you
three related lessons the first lesson
is around creating customer and employee
loyalty and a pretty unlikely setting
local supermarkets are not necessarily
known for treating their employees or
customers well they're known for
offering bad jobs with poverty level
wages unpredictable schedules and very
few opportunities for success and growth
they're also known to frustrate their
customers the market basket case shows
us that it doesn't have to be that way
here's a company that really puts a
focus on building those relationships
it's easy to say treat a customer as you
would like to be treated it's a lot
different to say that you would treat
your customers the way you treat your
family or your friends because there's a
lot of loyalty there the second lesson
that emerged from Market Basket is the
importance of employees and what they do
for efficient low-cost operations
you see Market Basket
pays its employees decent wages it
offers some generous benefits it treats
them with respect and dignity Market
Basket designs the jobs in a way that
allows their employees to be more
motivated that allows them to be more
productive and that allows them to
contribute more to the success of their
company it's not just working for the
paycheck it's working for what you're
getting out of the job getting that
feeling that you're providing something
in value that they appreciate and
appreciating somebody else that's a huge
motivator for me and carrying that
through the company to bring value to
the company who wouldn't want to work
for that if you go to a market basket
store you're gonna see a lot of
employees around a lot more than what
you see at a local supermarket why is
that
well Market Basket does that so that its
employees can do their jobs without
making errors so that they're not rushed
so that they can treat their customers
well help them out by necessary so that
they have enough time to engage in
continuous improvement come up with
suggestions to reduce costs and increase
customer service and sales appropriate
staffing levels is just one of the job
design decisions that motivate employees
make their jobs better so make them
happier that lead to happy customers
because they receive better service and
that also lead to happy remasters
because now the costs are lower sales
are higher and profits are higher and
that brings me to the third decision
related to Market Basket which is even
in a low cost supermarket setting it is
not only possible but highly profitable
to create a business model that creates
value for customers employees and
investors at the same time there's a lot
of focus on people you have eight owners
and shareholders and then you have
25,000 employees and then you have the
further impact of vendors and customers
that's a huge base now you're talking
millions of people and
here's a company that really puts a
focus on everyone who's involved with
our company now you might wonder is my
kid basket an exception is it unique
well certainly what Market Basket
employees did was pretty extraordinary
but market baskets business model is
hardly special in fact in my own
research I studied four other low-cost
retailers that do exactly the same
ranging from Costco to Kwik Trip a
convenience store chain with gas
stations that has been unfortunate
hundred best companies to work for 12
years narrow and that is extremely
profitable if good jobs are possible at
a setting like Kwik Trip
they are possible everywhere we just
need more companies to follow the good
job strategy and everyone can do their
part you our customers you can vote with
your feet you can decide the shop or
dine at places that offer good jobs for
those of you who are employees managers
or even investors in organizations then
you could be advocates for a good job
strategy finally I want to leave you
with one last thought at some point in
your career chances are you'll be a
manager you might manage just a few
people or hundreds of people remember
this the types of decisions that you
make are not just business decisions
they affect the lives of people so make
those decisions wisely
you